[Music]
despite a serene sunset on the de negro
river the mood is tense for the
zaporozhian cossacks the year is 1676
and the Treaty of sharavino has
officially ended hostilities between the
Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth and the
Ottoman Empire but as Stepan and his men
ride towards their stronghold peace is
far from their minds having made their
home in the wild fields north of the
Black Sea
these cossacks derived from a Turkic
word for free man are renowned as one of
Europe's most formidable military forces
composed of hunters fishermen nomads and
outlaws the Cossacks found freedom in
these fertile unclaimed lands yet this
freedom has proven increasingly
difficult to maintain their decades-long
strategy of shifting alliances between
Poland and Moscow has led to the
partitioning of their lands in a
desperate bid to reclaim independence
and reunite the fractured Cossack state
their most recent leader hetman Petro
doroshenko allied with the Ottoman
Empire this alliance successfully freed
the zaporozhian cossacks in the West
from polish dominion but their victory
was a bitter one doroshenko x' ottoman
allies ravaged the countryside carrying
off peasants into slavery and outraged
at a lying with Muslims against fellow
Christians cost him any remaining local
support now with doroshenko deposed and
exiled the Cossacks are at odds
disagreeing on what their next move
should be
until then Stepan must keep order with
his musket and curved saber he cuts an
imposing figure he surveys his battalion
of 180 men most are Orthodox Christians
and speak a Slavic language that will
become modern Ukrainian but there are
also Greeks - tarz
and even some mongolian comics many with
different opinions on recent events
officially all of Stefan's men have
sworn to uphold the Cossack code by
undergoing seven years of military
training and remaining unmarried in
practice some are part-timers holding
more closely to their own tradition
and maintaining families in nearby
villages outside Cossack lands
thankfully the tenuous peace is not
broken before they reached the sick the
center of Cossack military life
currently located at Charton Lake the
six location shifts with the tide of
military action the settlement is
remarkably well organized with
administrative buildings officers
quarters and even schools as Cossacks
prize literacy Stefan and his men make
their way to the barracks where they
live and train alongside several other
battalions or Koreans all of which make
up a several hundred man Regiment inside
the men dine on dried fish sheep's
cheese and salted pork fat along with
plenty of wine Stefan instructs his
friend Yuri to lighten the mood with his
Bundoora
but before long an argument has broken
out one of his men has raised a toast to
doroshenko Stefan cuts him off the room
is silent until he raises his own toast
to Ivan's circle the new headman who
favors an alliance with Moscow against
the Turks step on plans to support him
and he expects his men to do the same
suddenly one of circo's men rushes in
calling an emergency Rada or general
council meeting Stepan and the others
make their way towards the church square
the center of seek life
Ivan circle welcomes the confused crowd
with exciting news scouts have located a
large Ottoman camp completely vulnerable
on one side Sirico vows that tomorrow
they will ride against their common
enemy defend the cossacks autonomy and
bring unity to the wild fields as the
men cheer in unison Stepan is relieved
at their renewed sense of brotherhood
over the next 200 years these freedom
fighters would take on many foes and
tragically they would eventually become
the oppressive hand of the Russian
government
they once opposed but today these 17th
century Cossacks are remembered for
their spirit of Independence and
defiance as the russian painter ilya
repin once said no people in the world
held freedom equality and fraternity so
deeply find out what life was like for a
soldier of a very different era with
this lesson or check out the rest of the
videos in our day-in-the-life playlist
[Music]